all right guys well now i got to do my  quick scan of the crowd to make sure  will smith isn't here right because he  can never be too careful right i don't  want to get hit by anybody this guy gets  it where where'd you get that shirt huh  the the uh uh the the bad shirt store  you were clearly coming towards me man  you were coming towards me i was just  reaching for my drink okay well you  can't make sudden movements around a  comedian in in these times i wasn't  trying i wasn't trying to hit you but  all right like no fault on you man but  but like you should know better okay so  let me just  regain my composure real quick  okay sorry everyone i just need to make  this all about me somehow